i don't know how many of you are old
enough to remember sarah palin sarah
palin used to be the governor of wasilla
alaska she was john mccain's
presidential running mate in 2008. had
john mccain won
sarah palin would have been a heartbeat
away from the presidency which is a very
scary thought because she is
aggressively incompetent aggres
could have been
maybe
uh i i don't even think it's even close
would have been dramatically less
competent than even someone like a dan
quayle
so we really dodged a bullet in terms of
sarah palin not becoming the vice
president of the united states sarah
palin
recently said she will get a covet
vaccine over her dead body meaning she
she'll die before she gets a covet
vaccine sarah palin now has coveted
um and it is uh of course
raising a lot of questions as to whether
uh
what the course of the disease is going
to be reuters reporting sarah palin's
positive covet test delays her new york
times defamation trial which is also
just hilarious sarah palin has tested
positive for the virus forcing a u.s
judge to delay her defamation trial
against the new york times
it's particularly funny that her bogus
defamation trial now gets delayed
because she has covered jury selection
was expected to start monday push back
10 days after the test results for the
57 year old palin became known she was
expected to testify in person as soon as
today tuesday u.s district judge jed
rakoff in manhattan said she is of
course unvaccinated since she has
apparently tested positive three times
i'm going to assume she is positive
palin also tested positive last march
she has been she has objected to
mandatory vaccinations it will be over
my dead body that i will have to get a
shot here is the video of sarah palin
explaining that to turning point usa's
charlie kirk
remember this
and i will
it'll be over my dead body that i'll
have to get a shot i will not do it
right
crowd loves that
i won't do it and um
they better not touch my kids either
because that's that's where the
well governor some people say though i
might lose my job
i might get kicked out of school
yeah i know and um you know i think if
enough of us though
rise up and say new enough is enough
there are more of us than there are of
them okay anyway so over her dead body
she will get vaccinated let's really
hope it doesn't come to that now there's
a question as to whether she's really
unvaccinated or is claiming she is to
keep up appearances some people even
saying
i will
i will
have to get a shot over my dead body
which may be different than
i've gotten a shot by choice
but i won't get one by four so with all
these people it's like the desantis
thing were you boosted sir
well uh you know i uh got the normal
shot well so hold on are you boosted or
not no no i'm not gonna say that uh now
we could ask her but the truth is that
should really be between her and her
doctor because as you all know all of
these republicans believe that uh
medical decisions should be left to
women and their doctors when it comes to
women's health those are private matters
in which the state should have
what oh oh oh i'm sorry sorry i i now i
understand why it's so stupid to be
saying that so sarah palin has coveted
and she i guess will get a shot only
over her dead body
i am someone who loves documentaries i
would imagine many of you love them as
well you've got to check out our sponsor
curiosity stream it's the only streaming
platform
dedicated to documentaries i'm always
noticing curiosity stream has the best
selection of documentaries better than
netflix or any other platform and the
best part is it's only 15 bucks a year
when you click the link below and use
the code pacman which is an amazing deal
it's nearly endless documentary content
and whether you want to tune out and
watch something relaxing dive into
something really thought provoking
curiosity stream has both and everything
in between
i just got done watching pompeii
which is unbelievable i visited pompeii
when i was in italy and the documentary
filled in so much fascinating history
about it and the people who lived there
curiosity stream is giving my audience
25 office subscription that comes out to
14.99 a year a year go to
curiositystream.com
and use the code pacman the link is down
below